whenever there's violent conflict
anywhere in the world the geopolitical
chess match that ensues ends up leading
to uncertainty and chaos that's exactly
what we're seeing in russia ukraine
conflict now of course what we
understand is that nation-states have
come together and they're levying these
financial sanctions against russia
whether it's the banks whether it's the
central bank or it's the everyday
citizens or it's the leadership of the
country they're all getting hit with
economic sanctions but we have to
understand that these decisions are
there to optimize for short-term
mitigation of risk rather than looking
at the long-term problems that they
create and so ultimately economist steve
hank he hit a great point where he said
weaponizing the swift international
payment system might cut russia off but
risks eroding the dollar-denominated
global financial system indeed it will
give rise to alternative systems
developed by china and russia just
another example of why sanctions are
counterproductive now first let's unpack
exactly what these sanctions are doing
they're kicking russian banks out of the
global financial system it's not
allowing the leadership nor the average
citizen to go ahead and transact with
various other countries to buy goods and
services on the open market or to access
their wealth that sits outside of russia
or china now that sounds like a great
idea it sounds like it'll serve as a
deterrent it'll inflict maximum pain on
the russian citizens and hopefully get
them to pressure putin to make different
decisions or to remove him as a leader
but what it does is it also puts every
single country in the world on notice if
you use the us dollar system the health
and sovereignty of your financial system
is dependent on having a good
relationship with the united states if
all of a sudden the united states with
the click of a button can remove you
from the global financial system if they
can pressure their allies into doing the
exact same thing what we are going to
watch is countries around the world
starting to develop insurance policies
or backup plans they're not necessarily
going to run and just buy bitcoin the
decentralized digital currency that may
be one thing that they do but they're
also going to go ahead and they're going
to create non-us dollar denominated
trading accounts with their trading
partners they're going to go ahead and
start to develop central bank digital
currencies that operate on payment rails
that aren't reliant on swift or the us
dollar system there's going to be a
variety of options that are pursued but
ultimately these types of decisions that
inflict maximum pain in the short term
they try to mitigate the short-term
risks everything from the invasion of
ukraine all the way to potential nuclear
war they're being celebrated today as a
way to address the problems we're facing
but they're creating long-term problems
it makes the us dollar system much more
risky and less sustainable over a long
time horizon and so that's fine to
address the short-term problems many
people including myself would say what
we're doing is actually going to have an
impact today we just have to be aware of
the long-term problems that we may be
creating maybe we can handle it maybe we
can address those long-term problems in
the future or maybe not i don't know but
what i do know is that being aware of
optimizing for short-term risk
mitigation while also creating long-term
problems is something we have to be well
aware of today